[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is red lake hey
here we are here we are thanks for
having us
yes thanks for having me
yeah and you me is glad to be here with
you me is glad with us with us we're
glad to be here with them that could
pretty much go on all day but it won't
it's just the two of us rhettandlink
only ear biscuit yeah we're gonna be
talking about something that's
interesting to us and hopefully
interesting to you today and this is
what we've been doing well some of these
rhettandlink only ear biscuits lately we
have what we're kind of con like an
extended good mythical morning
conversation the kind of thing that we
would condense down into a list of about
10 minutes now we're going to dig down
get into more detail and have an
interesting conversation follow some
rabbit trails learn some new stuff for
about an hour
yeah so strap in somebody actually
called us out put your lip balm on using
the term rabbit trail and they said it's
not it's not going on a rabbit trail
it's going down the rabbit hole right
part of the country you're from yeah I
think in our part of the country there's
also rap have you been down a rabbit
trail you'll get lost real quick son
rabbit hole human can't even get in a
rabbit oh yeah you stick your mic stick
your nose in it try stick your hand in
it might get bit by a rabid rabbit a
little blonde girl can go down a rabbit
hole that's where that's from it's right
it's it's referring to a book later turn
into a movie I'm familiar with it and
that's what we're talking about today
misused colloquialism no we're not we're
talking about acquired savant syndrome
also known as accidental genius now this
is fascinating because both you and I
have been hit in the head pretty badly a
couple of times in our life and it has
resulted in some great stories
especially what happened with link you
can go on the internet and look on earth
just search links broken pelvis story
yeah yeah it's into you a whole thing
the only interesting thing that happen
to you is you just began repeating
evidently hold on I'm just coming to
evidently I hurt my left hip yeah that
was fascinating but it was nothing I did
not get smarter Oh
and that's what all of these are yes I
mean people get hit in the head and
becoming geniuses now you said
accidental genius but I've also never
met an intentional genius you either are
you're no I'm an intentional genius I
used to be a real stupid trying really
hard to be a genius I'll give you that
but I mean I'm a try-hard genius you
either are a genius or you aren't but
there's a but there's a subset of genius
I that don't think that's a word are
they got that way by getting hit in the
noggin and that's what we're talking
about today so I mean I feel like we
might need to put a warning on this I
think we are gonna get so excited you're
never gonna be prescribing getting hit
in the head we are not prescribing
hitting yourself in the head or doing
anything to get hit in the head but you
might want to be because these stories
I'm so excited to talk about it because
they're so fascinating they're so
amazing there's parts of this that I
want for myself I think we should dig
into that but all of this is real if we
were making any of this up well we'd be
more genius than we are
I think the warning up at the front is I
would say 99.9% of the time when people
get in the head in a way that we're
going to describe these people get you
let the word hit out you said get in the
head get hit in the head okay yeah okay
ninety-nine point whatever percent of
the time it doesn't end well you don't
get smart oh so I don't think this is
something you can plan so we're gonna
get into that but first we want to take
a moment to tell you about our sponsor
Squarespace Squarespace is the easiest
way to create a beautiful website blog
or online store for you and your ideas
Squarespace features an elegant
interface beautiful templates and
incredible 24/7 customer support
try squarespace is squarespace.com enter
code biscuits I know it's not the
easiest word to spell there's a C in it
it looks like bisquits but it's really
just biscuits if I know we don't have to
tell you guys how to spell biscuit just
look at a Google I'm sorry
none of us are geniuses here but we know
how to spell things we do so in our code
biscuits at checkout to get 10% off
squarespace.com offer code biscuits
square
space build it beautiful all right let's
uh let's get into this biscuit okay
first up is Ben McMahon from Melbourne
Australia early 2012 he's 20 years old
and he's a passenger in a very bad car
accident it puts him in a coma for a
week he almost dies okay but after one
week in a coma he finally woke up and
all he could speak was Mandarin well his
Australian guy who didn't speak Mandarin
okay let me give you a little bit more
information about this because it is
completely fascinating but if you speak
Australian but but it's not like there
was a Mandarin lesson plan in the DVD
player of the car that suddenly got like
shoved into his mouth and somehow his
brain absorbed it yes because that would
have been really cool that's not what I
was thinking okay Ben was an English
speaker he couldn't speak Mandarin
before his accident but he did have a
point of reference in high school only
years prior just you know a few years
prior to the accident
he studied French and Mandarin and he
also traveled and spent some time in
Beijing but he can never speak Mandarin
fluently until he woke up from his coma
so it's one of those things where he had
learned quite a bit about it but had
never put it into practice to actually
be able to speak it so kind of like I
took three years of French class as did
I I speak I can say just Swede Renee and
I rolled my art which is not even
appropriate for French you could I have
no idea how to speak French yeah almost
said speak France to give you just a
point of reference right but I was in
class for three years you know
supposedly exposed to things and maybe
there's a part of my brain that has it
because this guy's miss Raine we had it
right so he wakes up
Wow so it's like him getting hit in the
head after the coma it's like it
unlocked that place Rhett where all this
information was and here's how it
happens he wakes up from his coma
after being in a coma for a week almost
dying there's an Asian nurse I don't
know if that's a key to this process
working but there's an Asian nurse
standing by his side he's in Australia
but he sees an asian nurse and he tells
her in Mandarin
excuse me nurse I feel really sore here
he points
I don't know where he pointed I don't
he's not I don't have a video of it
that's not pertinent he then asked for a
pen and paper and wrote in Chinese oh
wow I love my mum I love my dad I will
recover here's what Ben said about this
priorities he said loving those parents
I wasn't consciously thinking I was
speaking Mandarin it was just what came
out and what was most natural to me and
then it takes him two or three days to
start speaking speaking English again
and now he speaks both languages
fluently but his go-to language on the
other side of the coma was Mandarin yeah
exclusively in a way that it had never
been
it wasn't like his brain made a choice
it was that it opened up something that
had never been opened in a Mandarin
valve do we all as humans have a
Mandarin valve that just needs to be
opened I highly doubt that but but I
don't have him but it isn't a valve is
it a valve that French would come out
mmm if it were open for us after three
years probably not a valve it's probably
a part of the brain but there's so
little we know about the brain that
these anomalies well there is a our
window into that well okay and and
plumbing analogies I'm certain go a long
way in neuro stead of you conjecturing
and you know saying that there was
potentially a valve that was unlocked
I'm gonna tell you what dr. Pankaj saw a
Queensland brain institute
neuroscientist says about this he said
can you tell me in Mandarin no he said
the brain has different circuits that
assist in language speaking breathing
and thinking and he claims it as
possible that the parts of Ben's brain
that could recall English got damaged
during the crash while those parts that
retain Mandarin got activated when he
woke up from the coma so we're not
exactly sure what happened during the
coma but it's like he got it's like his
brain compensated and went for the other
part that the other language it rewired
itself and it wasn't temporary because
listen to this he after this he enrolled
in a Mandarin class I don't
why I guess to dominate I know him but
he entered an international Chinese
language competition he started which
exist Mandarin walking tours and even
hosted a Chinese TV show he is now known
as the best Mandarin speaking Westerner
in China and some Chinese people say he
speaks better Mandarin than then dude
totally capitalizes this freaking he
became the most he became a celebrity
came a celebrity just by being up on
that white do can speak some any better
than us he's gotta be like a TV game
show host exactly I mean if I'm gonna
like turn a corner after something bad
happens to me like it doesn't get any
better than being a TV ho oh no
definitely like a game show that is the
peak that is that is where you've got to
go it's like any it's like you have a
superhuman ability now I'm not gonna
fight crime I'm not gonna like let me
host the show I'm not gonna fight like
technical writing Mandarin crime no I'm
gonna I'm gonna be a gameshow celebrity
well I didn't say gameshow that's what
you heard
did I say gameshow I thought I said
Chinese TV show oh well but I like to
say it was probably thinking like
Japanese game show I think you said game
show and Mandarin in air you didn't know
what is abloom Italy yeah really is a
quiet spoke Mandarin you don't know what
you're saying I think that's what it was
well here's a question for us but I also
noticed that the the scientific
explanation used electrical analogies
because the brain is electrical impulses
but I'm still gonna lobby for the valve
plumbing and Alex okay so I'm just gonna
keep going back to that even though I
know in an electrical world in there
maybe his trap was his trap was cloth
his english trap was clogged in the
mandarin pipe they went in there to let
it mother it up the valve yeah we should
we should start our own University
what's your question here's a question
for us it is would you willingly be in a
car accident mm-hmm that would be this
traumatic but here's the thing
you know that you will recover fully
okay but you will be in a coma for a
week I know this is a totally
hypothetical impossible situation but
let's just say I was a magic person and
I was and I was the kind of person who
could say you can be in a car wreck
right now you're almost gonna die
don't you mean a magician yeah I'm gonna
be oh no this is a magic person there's
a totally different category magicians
do fake stuff but a magic person does
real magic oh wow okay it's like a genie
but is it different okay
okay so you've got to go through this
process but when you come out you can
speak any other language fluently but
the price you pay is the accident would
you do would you sign up for that you
have to go through the pain of recovery
but you will recover
hmm I mean there's there's a lot of
emotional baggage that comes along with
being an accident that I can't quantify
having not done it but I know there's
like I mean that can stick I I can't
quantify that but let's just say that
emotionally and mentally like there's no
repercussions of the accident right and
no one else is hurt yeah yeah it's like
rosetta stone but it's just a wreck yeah
would that cost more than the DVDs or
less yeah I think it yeah cuz you gotta
have a stunt coordinator are you I guess
up a doctor first I have to ask what the
I have to answer what the language would
be you pick the language rosetta stone I
have to be I'm to go on a website and
you pick the language and then a week
later that we pick you up and have a
wreck with you I have two answers I'm
I've already opened up this business I
just hope helping you would be on board
I think it would have to be Spanish and
I think I would have to know the answer
to that before I answer the larger
question we've got to go through it well
I don't know I got to think about game
shows now like what type of what land
would I like to host a game show and
it's really what your ass is right
that's pertinent so I mean I would love
to host Icelandic no that's not you not
a lot of I don't think there's a lot of
not enough viewers I definitely would do
Spanish and I'd host a Spanish frickin
game show I would also just speak
Spanish in LA which comes in very bright
that's why I first said Spanish but now
that I'm thinking game show I'm thinking
Japanese
they have the best freaking game shows
ever I don't let you and I am going to
be that that American dude who speaks
Japanese better than anybody and hosts
all those Japanese game shows that's me
well you better absolutely this is now
an easy you've got to get started now
though because when my program hits the
internet what everybody's gonna be doing
it Rhett's rosetta wreck rosetta wreck
cd-rom series yeah so that's my idea I
am so excited about being in a Japanese
game show okay well it'll it's five
hundred thousand dollars well I mean
that's like a weekly salary for game
show host they're the highest paved
people probably outside of Japanese
government okay you got something better
than that no but I do have Tommy McHugh
okay
he sounds interesting bar brawler turned
art savant savant alright so tell me
week you live in Liverpool and spent
most of his life causing trouble this
dude always getting into brawls at pubs
you know how Liverpool Ian's like they
they just brawl in pubs Mulligan's and
he was arrested for drugs when he was
like in his 20s picture this dudes like
he's tatted up burly scruffy Liverpool
Ian commands man in and out of prison I
mean prison tattoo kind of a dude all
right not the kind of guy you see
drawing pictures of writing poetry I'll
tell you that mm-hmm okay one day back
in 2001 Tommy was sitting on the toilet
that's a good place to sit he was not in
jail at the time yeah because that's a
bad place to sit I'm gonna get that over
with quickly but he had this real bad
headache and now I will say I've had a
few headaches yeah and I've been so
desperate to get rid of them that I've
honestly I've actually thought I wonder
if I just use the restroom if that will
help like I've I haven't I don't get
migraines I'm never looking at me like
I'm an idiot not connected I don't suck
there's not a valve between the brain
and the rectum I've I've had headaches
so bad I'm willing to try almost
anything to get rid of them and I that's
one of the things I've tried okay a
bowel movement and I know that's often
that's a rabbit or maybe a BM will help
you feel better my mom used to say that
so and it it doesn't really help so I'm
just gonna that's my friendly piece of
advice but Tommy had a really bad
headache he's on the toilet turns out it
was a brain hemorrhage that's bad dude
brain started to bleed not from one but
from both sides due to ruptured
rupturing aneurysms and he was
immediately rushed to surgery I don't
even know if they pulled his pants up
back up before they did it so I hope so
I hope you know don't dude you can't
strain that hard I mean I'm just oh you
think this is a hemorrhoid I don't know
I'm just saying if you're straining so
hard that you have a double hemorrhage
it is unlikely that I'm gonna be king
aneurysms on both sides at the same time
he made it out of surgery alive but when
he got home he started doing some very
bizarre things for the first three
months after his surgery he spoke only
in weird rhymes oh he's like he became
like a dr. Seuss book like this is
interesting
like wordsmith from that obscure
junkyard cats cartoon that I used to
watch as a kid there was a cat one of
the cows cowork Smith and everything he
said rhymed
because he was the guy that did
everything on time I just tried to make
a rhyme I can't do it you had an
aneurysm
no you're just demonstrating so three
months just talking in poetic dot I mean
that's pretty cool well well I get I got
to take issue with that
because I think it would be pretty
frustrating for me if I was his friend
because yeah I remember when you came
out of your when you had your concussion
and yeah we're saying evidently I hurt
my left hip over and over again I was as
I telling the story on the Internet 100%
sure that you were joking and I was like
how long is he gonna let this because we
were ended like joking with people and
pranking people College so I was like
how long is this going to take
if you were in an accident and you came
out only speaking in rhymes I would be
like Linc you gotta end this joke cuz
it's not funny anymore
like a a few hours later okay that's
enough few days later okay that's enough
three months later okay I wouldn't be
his friend anymore your brain is
different now now he was a construction
worker never in his 50 years of getting
drunk and fighting people and pubs did
he express any level of creativity much
less speaking Ron he had never rhyme
anything well he started writing down
poetry one of which I have here for our
enjoyment the empty chair fills me with
despair no one is sitting there all
three rhymes in the empty room fills me
with the gloom till black rose blood
bloom the empty bed my love is dead
we're loving words were once said the
empty clothes do make me cry costumes of
a time gone by my empty heart cannot
restart love has gone away
I am split into these words are true as
I empty myself of you I mean that
doesn't sound like some dude who's
punching in the face in a in a like a
pub brawl but if he did that would be
like an epic Tarantino character what
it's you know like speaking in rhyme and
just like ripping your teeth out with
your hike but like a bare-knuckle it's
fascinating that he would have almost a
personality change I gotta say
personality change I'm not terribly
impressed by the poetry I'm impressed by
the let me give you more the the shift
he started seeing all kinds of images
and words in his mind he decided to
start sketching them out okay one day
his wife comes home to find him drawing
alien faces like with their mouths a
game like garage situation yeah well
it's kind of like really surprised
aliens like turning the tables like
we're supposed to be surprised by
anything I don't know he had this like
artistic explanation for everything the
dude became the opposite of somebody he
would ever be who was obsessed with
writing painting it's called anything
our
test he became he used his own walls as
canvases covered his entire home in
paintings this is and there was a
construction worker different different
guy now he started sending letters out
to doctors asking them to take a look at
him and of course the letters were
written as poems he arrived
oh how do you respond to that well a
team of researchers put him through
every cognitive test imaginable included
that yes his artistic output was due to
his brain sudden decision to start
bleeding which caused some damage to his
frontal lobe the exact cause is unknown
doctors have named it sudden artistic
output I mean I think that's what
doctors live for us like well I'm just
gonna I'm able to name this it seems
like they could have come up with a
better name like I don't like Tommy's
artist
Tommy's really in the art now syndrome
what is B dude that would just be Tommy
though any true so but okay I don't
understand what what happened damage to
the frontal lobe I mean they don't know
he had some pins put in to stop the
bleeding so they couldn't do an MRI they
I know you know it's just some doctors
guessing so it's one of the it's the
brain there's just who knows you know
the weird thing is that something gets
damaged which causes another part of the
brain to become emphasized rest a vowel
you know the artists valve was in an
interesting way because you can't
it isn't like blowing on a Nintendo
cartridge right when you think about
that you're like how does that work how
does blowing on a Nintendo cartridge get
Legend of Zelda that boot-up in the
right way that makes total sense the
dust that was on the part that was
keeping it from booting up was was was
okay honey that does make more sense but
it's almost like creating something out
of nothing if you're not artistic before
something gets shut off shutting off of
something that turns something else on
you can't make a part of the brain work
better by hitting
hard right or shaking something loose
shaking something right
shaking something shaking something into
place what no I wear I mean we're no
neuroscientist but it just tells me that
like you're there's all these building
blocks they're like everything's there
it's just a question of what's expressed
so meaning that it was in his brain
already be an artist there was an artist
in there right but it had been sitting
it was a brawler in there and it subdued
or just one both weren't expressed like
only one was expressed and then it was
depressed and then another was expressed
I'm using like landscaping terms now I'm
thinking like sprinklers we can only
come up with analogies because we don't
understand it why we don't understand it
I mean when he explains that he says my
mind is like a volcano exploding with
the bubbles and each bubble contains a
million other bubbles and then another
million bubbles of unstoppable creative
ideas he also went on to write the anime
he actually became a much nicer person
and he doesn't drink and bar fight he
wishes he'd always been that way if you
could have one part of your brain
unlocked assuming that everything that
you know about everybody is in all of
our brains and you can unlock one part
and I had to have a horrible
constipation session in order to make it
happen yes but what part of the brain
would it be like I you know I think we
kind of see see ourselves is like kind
of well-rounded individuals but cute but
if there's a limitation you know we're
not it's funny or what you analytical or
you know it's yeah I've always said I'm
good at a lot of things will happen
I'm not your way to make an appointment
in the future and unlock certain things
right and but you're not gonna know
what's gonna get locked up in order to
create it I allow that to that sprinkler
to open when you water the one in the
front yard of these the backyards gonna
dry up oh no I this is all this is all
leading to something inevitably there
we'll be a time in which you will be
able to undergo surgery they'll figure
this out and know and you'll be what are
you gonna choose you're near my question
greatness because what I was gonna say
is I've always thought yeah I'm not
afraid to say I feel like I'm good at a
lot of things I don't think I'm great at
anything mm-hmm you know it's like I can
hold my own with music enough to enough
to write something that's catchy right
but it ain't is no musical genius that's
for sure
hey I think I feel like at this stage in
my life it would either be like the
ability to write something really
incredible
you know like story wise or or something
musical musical related and I'd have to
pick one of those the interesting thing
is okay what would you be willing to
give up that you're as decent at as
music at now in order to like express
the music sprinkler entirely what in the
backyard is gonna go dry when the
musical front yard flourishes niceness I
want to become a total jerk musician
that's really you cannot dial that up
it's sad
no I mean can you kidding can't can
you'd sacrifice athletic ability sure
yes I would sacrifice that because I
don't use that very often okay I use it
a lot of my younger days but I would
become you know horrible at anything
physical to be a good musician to be a
great musician what about you Oh what
about me I like the I've always said
like the varieties of spice of life I'm
decent enough and enough things that
just I just like to do a little thing
and be good and move on to something
decent at it and enjoy it and move on
like I'm just trying to think what what
I could do if that sit down at the piano
and like do something amazing how much I
can't it's hard for me to quantify how
much joy I would actually get from it
having never cuz I get joy from the
little things and then move
you know so it's just it's almost like
it's a different mentality I don't think
I would say something to a new level
though but but it's giving something
else up okay well it's giving a
mediocrity of I would what variety up
well I've got a guy so that's what I'm
not willing to do I got a guy who gave
up nothing Oh
in game musical genius his name is Tony
Sakura in Albany New York 1994 he's a 42
year old orthopedic surgeon he goes to a
pay phone to call his mom
it is 1994 they still had payphones that
people actually used he hangs up he sets
one foot away from the payphone and he
is struck by lightning again not
constipation but pretty traumatic struck
by like Mia he says he then sees his own
body on the ground surrounded by bluish
white light so sort of an out of body
experience here surrounded by bluish
white light yeah Sakura is heart what
did he become the payphone uh no I don't
believe so
what's the payphone got to do with it
that's just where he was oh so it has
nothing to do with it Sakura's heart had
apparently stopped but he was
resuscitated by a woman who happened to
be a nurse that was waiting to use the
payphone 1994 not only are people using
the payphone there's a line there's a
line for the payphone
can you imagine that I can't even locate
a payphone I couldn't find a payphone if
you paid me to find the payphone you
could pay me in a payphone I couldn't
find a payphone me neither but okay for
the next couple of weeks after the
strike Tony's feeling sluggish first a
nurse is also a good person to be there
when you're struck by line yeah it helps
and it's nice to have a payphone because
you can't name one yeah it all works out
he's a few weeks after the strike he's
feeling sluggish sound trouble
remembering things
is he still watching himself from above
no that was temporary
that was temporary and I just a little
sidebar on the whole out-of-body
experience thing just for those of you
interested in this it has been this
phenomenon has been
documented and lots of different people
and there's actually some really
interesting explanations the common
denominator a payphone that people the
experience seeing themselves when they
have a near-death experience not
necessarily saying that you're actually
leaving your body but there's an
interesting neurological things that
happen during that time there kind of
help to explain this whole out-of-body
thing but regardless of what's actually
happening anyway but these symptoms of
not me know remember things and feeling
kind of sluggish they go away and then
things get weird
out of the blue Tony who's never been
musical gets a sudden urge to listen to
piano music okay he's just kind of a
technical guy a surgeon now he had
played piano for one year
just like forced to take piano lessons
at age seven by his parents he did not
like it though so but he had never done
anything else with music okay but he
doesn't just start wanting to listen to
piano music he finds that he is hearing
piano music in his head his brain and it
is he's hearing it crystal-clear and
it's new original music that he's hears
playing in his head
really and then he figures out the
composer that he can just sit down
having no idea how to play the piano and
not knowing how to read or write music
but he can sit down and play what he
hears in his head well he's he it's not
he doesn't have any I it's not that he
doesn't have any idea he's reacts essing
and opening the valve from the seven
year old but then applying some other
part of the brain to it to just speak
the language of music using his fingers
it's it's unbelievable and he goes on to
become I mean he what this guy does now
is he he writes music he's a musician
here is is he like touring with Josh
Groban or something I mean is this guy
is playing an appropriately named
lightning sonata this is in Vienna and
you'll notice right before he plays this
I'm not I'm just gonna play you some of
the music but right before he plays this
he says I received this one from the
other side so I can't claim that I wrote
it so from his perspective he's got he
has access to some musical dimension
that he's now accessing and then he's
just writing it and playing it so if
somebody paid him will you keep the
money or would he send it to the other
side I don't know I don't know how you
send money to that side I think he'd go
back to the pay phone right
[Music]
okay I get it okay he's good at the
piano I get it you know you could have
played anything on the pianos oh yeah
okay you can play the piano good all
right okay here's the thing I love about
this story now I know what to tell my
kids when they don't want to do their
praiano practice you know Lily and
Lincoln are both doing it because as a
kid now I wish as a kid that I would
have learned to play piano oh yeah like
I I do that's why that's what kid of
mine earlier because that's something I
wanted to give my kids that I the piano
can translate it's a great way to get
into music yeah it translates yeah and
you know I was over Lincoln shoulder
trying to get him to practice the other
night and getting really frustrated cuz
I'm I'm so impatient and such a horrible
teacher while I wasn't teaching him I
was just trying to get him to do what
the teacher was telling him and it's
homework and now I have a story could be
Lincoln you're gonna thank me one day
when you get struck by lightning when
you're calling your mama and all this is
gonna come back to you and you're gonna
be even better at it than you are now
it's like it's like it's like a savings
bond of concerto you know you put in a
little ten-year-old version of the piano
now in your brain and then it'll grow up
and 12 years from now when you get
struck by lightning it will it will have
mature yeah well it's about you without
you doing anything in your sleep and not
just that we have to arrange that you
know this is why this is really supports
my long-held theory that there's music
and lightning bolts and that's what we
and all you got to do is find that high
spot during a thunderstorm you know
everybody wants to get down in the ditch
everybody wants to be inside get under
the tallest tree I mean go there you
know if you want to become a master
pianist right I hope for the record I
hope that no one will actually do that I
hope that people know that you think
people know I'm being sarcastic if they
do I hope they don't write a letter or
tell anyone that's why and then they die
right they can't tell anyone don't you
didn't get struck by lightning probably
won't become a mess
pianist I'm uh it to me it's if there
was no point of reference for the piano
that would just be or Mandarin like
though it would just it would be
mind-blowing but it
I just wouldn't believe it it's yeah I
mean is there's a little incredibly cool
it's it's almost on a brain mechanical
level it this is more fascinating
because right you know just enough to
know it's not magic mad it's not magic
that it's it's in there right and it
incubates and but when it and when it
manifests itself it's to a savant level
well and this is this guy's been studied
Tony's been studied by a Columbia
University neurologist Oliver Sacks
whose conclusion is I cannot provide an
exact medical explanation for the course
condition yeah I mean isn't that it's
just fascinating that there's just so
much that we don't know there's so much
that we don't know but I definitely feel
like these cases in which again we were
talking to Kevin who held research for
this episode who said that there's only
about 25 cases of this thing happening
in the world so we're just experiencing
the very beginning of this thing but
there's absolutely no doubt that a
hundred two hundred years from now
whether it's through nanotechnology or
just some injection that you'll be able
to rewire your brain to access some new
level of potential that whole Lucy movie
and that whole like what's the one with
Bradley Cooper limitless that hold that
all that's totally legit man that it may
be not exactly like it happened but it's
gonna happen and you know what remind me
I want to come back to this at the end
but just the thought about our brains
and how we view technology outside of
our brains that come back to that okay
right now we got to take a quick break
from these brain stories and tell you
about something else that requires a lot
of brainpower building a website Rhett
named a profession my mind needs
websites man Miley mobs needs websites
do you know
you know of mimes websites yeah mimes no
I don't personally frequent mime
websites but I'm just trying to make the
point that everybody needs a website
could use an occupation that doesn't
speak and just uses really do what mimes
do they certainly need a website they
need any help they can get to
communicate but I could put some video
on there of how you know this is me
coming out of the box this is me stuck
in the box this is me going down the
stairs going up the stairs right
portfolio website point made everyone
needs a website Squarespace provides
simple powerful and beautiful websites
that look professionally designed
regardless of your skill level no coding
required and not only does Squarespace
provides you with an intuitive and easy
way to use tools to create your website
but your site will be secure and stable
Squarespace is easy and simple they give
you 24/7 online support and a beautiful
website for only $8 a month you can even
get a free domain if you by Squarespace
for the year so begin a trial with no
credit card required and start building
your website today y'all when you decide
to sign up make sure to use offer code
biscuits to get 10% off your first
purchase and show your support of the
show offer code biscuits 10% off
Squarespace and thanks to Squarespace
for their support of air biscuit
Squarespace build it beautiful I also
want to thank our other sponsor
audible.com this I'm totally serious
here you're audible.com has
revolutionized the way that I consume
books because I'm the kind of person
well yeah you used to do it with your
eyes now you do it with your ears no
because here's the deal I and the kind
of person who loves the idea of reading
books but never gets around to actually
reading them nearly as much as I like
the idea of it but now that I've started
listening to books I'm actually I'm
gonna say that I'm reading the books I
am consuming the books I'm learning the
things that are in the books and I do a
lot of this while I'm driving and it's
much better than those thing I see
people doing you know the people who are
like reading a novel and they're holding
it up in front of their freaking
steering wheel I've actually seen this
yeah yes
people are still doing that and they
could just be listening to the book it's
crazy
I've gone through a more books in the
past two months as I've been using
audible than I have in the previous you
know two years easily it's almost like
getting hit getting hit in the head
mm yeah that's a great well you know
I've been haven't you listened to a book
over 180,000 titles so you'll find
something that will keep your attention
the audible app is free and works on
iPhones iPad Android and Windows Phone
you can also download and listen on your
Kindle Fire and over 500 mp3 players a
500 mp3 players are there 500 different
types of it is the only one I can hang
out with
unlike streaming a rental service with
audible you own the books you can access
your books anytime anywhere right from
your smartphone audible.com also has the
great listen guarantee if you decide you
don't like the book you chose hey no
worries you can exchange any book you
aren't happy with for any other title
any time no questions asked also as a
special for ear biscuits listeners
audible.com is offering a free audio
book of your choice and a free 30-day
trial membership go to audible.com slash
rhett and Link today to start your free
trial again show your support for ear
biscuits and get a free audiobook in
30-day trial at audible.com audible.com
slash rhett and Link that is a indie
spelled out not to ampersand that won't
work all right back into this biscuit
Jason Padgett is the name of a guy that
we went to high school I'm gonna say
that sounds like somebody had to high
school with but as it turns out there's
another Jason Padgett in Tacoma
Washington oh we did not judge it yes
big guy real big like muscular I was
thinking Jason Batson no Jason Batson
was was a different guy different name
Jason Padgett we barely knew him but I
hadn't thought of his name until I'm but
tell you about this guy who's not him
yeah so we shouldn't even be talking to
a guy but you know how when I'm sorry
guys when you when the name comes up man
I haven't heard that name in a long time
let me see if I can figure out who it is
he's a big guy I don't you know you get
hung up Yeah right my brain won't let me
let go of this but now we're gonna shut
down the old Jason Padgett part of the
brain open up the new Jason bedroom yes
we're gonna Express is a savant
alright this dude is a furniture
salesman in Tacoma Washington in 2002
two men savagely attack him outside of a
karaoke bar before robbing him who's
gonna that's rough that's it's cold
someone's been at a karaoke bar nice
singing islands in the stream in the
background you're getting your head in
that's horrible
they hit him over the head from behind
and left him with a severe concussion
and post-traumatic stress disorder I
mean it's bad I mean and he had been
doing karaoke like you likely don't work
well no sometimes you come off a good
karaoke run I mean sometimes I've really
nailed it a few times right the incident
also turned Jason Padgett the one that
we didn't go to high school with into a
mathematical genius who now sees the
world through fractals what is it yes
this guy's like the poster child for
turning lemons into lemonade yeah I used
to just be a guy who sold furniture was
singing karaoke and got the crap beat
out of me behind the karaoke bar and now
I'm a mathematical genius who sees the
world as fractals I mean what I I have a
I know what a fractal looks like and but
it makes no sense to me how do you see
the world in fractals well I'll tell you
how he explains it first of all he said
he back in school he always hated math
but the injury unlocked the part of his
brain that makes everything in his world
appear to have a mathematical structure
it's like he has a superpower he sees in
math that's it's like a filter over his
eyes he said I see shapes and angles
everywhere in real life from the
geometry of a rainbow to fractals and
water spiraling down a drain it's just
really beautiful well I hope it's
beautiful
I want this guy to sell me furniture
sounds like it would drive it drive me
crazy no I mean he's in awe of it this
is a fractal couch I know you can't tell
but it's a Miss fractals man he's a
sectional sofa is just full of fractals
he just went back to his in my god and
he's just like stare
furniture it likes it as if it's the
most beautiful thing you know I've never
been on acid don't plan on it
but it seems like that's what this guy
would look like staring at a couch like
it's amazing well hopefully he can
control a little bit better than that
Barrett brogard a philosophy professor
at the University of Miami scanned
Paget's brain so you got a philosophy
got skin in his brain
it showed significant activity in the
left hemisphere hemisphere which we're
mathematical skills are known to reside
so that makes sense his brain lit up
mostly in the left parietal cortex I
think I'm saying that right the area
behind the crown of the head that is
known to integrate information from
different senses so I mean we have a
little bit more information about this
guy that okay there's this integrate
into information integration Center and
mathematical skill center and it's
lighting up you know that that's what
you would expect to like this super
electric degree that he can he's tapped
into this dormant area again where this
resides and everyone like if I could
find this place in your brain and
stimulate it correctly correctly correct
man simulators curricula I can't speak
while doing it
but you're speaking in fractals now you
would seek couches you turn correctly
into correctly I like an amazing
geometry teacher he started sketching
but but the stuff that he was the stuff
that he was seen he would sketch like
circles made of overlapping triangles
and he began to understand the concept
of Pi in like a mind-blowing way he
didn't have any formal understanding to
interpret the drawings that he himself
was making he had he was just make me
just do it making the drawings out of
instinct a physicist happened to walk by
him in a mall dude was Jason was just
sitting in a mall sketching things that
he was seeing furniture a physicist walk
there's a chair here's a loveseat and
he's like oh that's he you know he
strikes up a conversation and says dude
you need to get mathematical training
because the stuff you're drawing is
amazing and when you look at it it's
like it's like looking at us like reline
drawings that you could see in a
kaleidoscope like perfectly geometric
drafting table level precision drawing
like something you see a 3d program yeah
Euler this guy's just drawing them out
of instinct and and now he's just he's a
sophomore in school as an aspiring I
can't speak anymore
notice like my brain is so overwhelmed
with this knowledge that shutting it
then maybe my Language Center is
shutting down butts and I'm happening
room for something else that has nothing
to do with I'm anticipating I'm so
anxious as to what it might be he's an
aspiring number theorist and he's like
being trained to do it and he loves it
this is it's not resonating with the new
brain that he's got but this this
concept of the kind of word that this
doctor used was that there was a dormant
part of his brain yeah that we
potentially have it just makes me wonder
why why what why is that there and what
do you mean by dormant is this a part of
the brain that was used at some point in
the history of our ancestors you know
way way back like a part you know how
your brain has different layers that you
have in common with you know other
life-forms and it's like you access
different parts depending on certain
emotions or certain things you're doing
wait is this part of his brain that he
now has access to that we probably have
in our brain but we don't have access to
it what is that what does that mean well
right I'll tell you exactly what it
means no I mean of course I don't know I
mean that's the fascinating thing is
that even the people who know are we're
still are still guessing and having
making analogies and it's like space
exploration well did you see did you see
that movie Lucy with Scarlett Johansson
no so not a great movie just
say right up front not a great movie I
saw the one where she was just the voice
her witch locked feet was a current
movie but in Lucy which also had Morgan
Freeman in it she is the subject of some
I came from exactly how it happens where
there's like something she takes or
something the way she's operated on I
can't remember but she basically gains
access to her entire birth the entire
usage of her brain and it's based on the
whole 10% of the brain you know we don't
use but 10% of our brain at a time or
whatever that old thing was the idea of
being able to access every part of your
brain she becomes just this amazing
being who can do all this stuff that
seems supernatural and beyond just being
really smart and just she's doing all
kinds of weird stuff but that idea this
kind of gives credence to that it's a
question of is it is it a hidden secret
that's been that's been placed within
the brain to be unlocked or is it the
byproduct of biological processes that
just happens to be advantageous or we're
on the precipice of unlocking it if we
just hit our noggins right well is there
some analogy and in like machines or
computers that we use in in like oK
you've got in an oven or a microwave or
a blender and you drop the blender and
all of a sudden there's like a new
setting on the blender that does just
happen you know you drop a blender and
like all of a sudden you can't chop
anymore it it isn't like you can now you
can like dice things but that you
couldn't do before
well how things because it's not a
living beam it is a little point that
out well and it doesn't have a brain and
doesn't have a brain that has a lot of
listed plasticity and the ability to
just you know brains are we don't
understand on they're malleable there's
just so much potential in them we're not
blenders link
that's that's the conclusion we're not
blenders but maybe if we put our brains
into a blender maybe that's maybe that's
what we need to do well you first okay
on with the amazing things that have
happened to people Orlando Serrell in
1979 he's 10 years old he's playing a
baseball game with his friends he runs
the first base the baseball is thrown in
his direction strikes him on the left
side of the head I knew that was gonna
happen he falls at the ground stays
there for a while unconscious then he
gets up and starts playing baseball
again
he walked it off ok but since that
injury Orlando can tell you the day of
the week and the weather on every date
after this accident ok I understand so
he's a weather man so if you say orlando
june 19 1998 almost immediately he
doesn't like even look like he's
thinking he just looks like you asked me
a question and now i'm giving you an
answer he'll say Friday sunny it was a
Friday I don't know what the weather was
ok can I point out that how would anyone
check this the accuracy of this well it
well it's been it has been checked I
actually saw this guy in a disco ball
Discovery Channel talk to him no he was
not at a booth I saw him on a Discovery
Channel documentary he's also been on
Dateline NBC or they they visited him
and they demonstrated this he can also
remember some details about the things
that he did that day like oh I ordered a
pizza with pepperoni and sausage on that
day but he says that he's not
remembering it he's when you give him a
date it's like he's reading it he says
he can see the details right in front of
him just like on it like he's accessing
information from a screen Wow now this
is he's not thinking this is fascinating
but it's also sad
because so what you know it's like what
good help you I'm trying to I'm trying
to help the guy I'm like how could it
this is rich is like I get you on
television get you on it gets you'd be a
subject matter on your biscuits I know
that's not bad about that he's like a
very specific he's just a database I
mean he's a weather database but you
know sometimes I think about weather
database I yeah but yeah I don't when
you have Orlando as a friend you never
go to weather calm but he can't tell you
the next that you can't tell you
tomorrow's weather so I guess you still
know since when have you gone to any
where to ask for when the weather was
what was the weather has I don't know
Farmers Almanac Minh is an anti
weatherman he's a negative weatherman I
think it's like the Farmers Almanac
he can predict the next year pretty
accurately but I could always just go
based on historical data so daylight NBC
invites Orlando to Columbia University
in New York to perform a functional MRI
test on his brain so I want to see what
lights up during the procedure they
videotaped Orlando undergoing undergoing
the MRI and then use it to compare his
brain functions to that of normal people
so they asking questions about dates in
the past you know same thing like June
19th 1998 and the control group when you
ask them about the weather of a day in
the past their responses so what I I
don't know why you know who cares and he
is told to only think about the answers
but not say them out loud here's what
they find it's really fascinating in
addition to using the part of the brain
that normal people would use for
computation Orlando was also using the
limbic area of the brain which is
associated with emotion okay but dr.
Hirsh who was the doctor who was doing
this concluded based on the scans at
Orlando is not using the memory part of
his brain when calculating the weekdays
he's using emotions basically I think
the answer is we don't know what he's
doing but he's using his brain in a way
that normal people don't he's not doing
something
better because me and you if you ask us
a date we'd have to like get out we'd
have to it would take me an hour to do a
bunch of math and to like dried it all
out to like just go back to like you
know three months ago to figure out what
day of the week something was mm-hmm
he's not doing that he's doing it
alternate processing time yeah he's not
moving through computations quite faster
he's doing he's accessing the
information immediately using a
combination of the compute the
computation part of his brain and the
emotional part of his brain they
basically don't really understand what's
going on he was able to observe that
it's different here's what I want to
know how they discovered this you know
it's probably not just he can tell you
the web with the day of the week and
what the weather was it's probably more
generic than that or more general
there's other things he can remember
like you said he can remember it's not
just oh he he's there's some special
unlocked valve in like the weather day
data bank no big rain yeah it's it's
probably more broad than that he can
remember other things but that's just
how it's being packaged for Dateline and
for us well it's like I think well it's
it's like he's constantly playing a
recorder that he can immediately access
the information but the thing the minute
waiting it records is the day in the
weather yeah it's like his brain is
doing something totally different it's
like his brain became a different tool
than what a typical brain would be so
but the fascinating thing is is it's
obviously this isn't a it's an amazing
thing but I agree with you that it's a
relatively useless thing it's amazing
that it happened but let's just say the
principle is you know getting hit in the
side of the head with a baseball in the
perfect way when you're 10 years old can
unlock something fascinating if you
could unlock some powerful memory
technique what would it be like you know
what if it was every song I've ever
listened to I don't know all that
I'm that that would be awesome and talk
let's talk about karaoke you know I mean
all of a sudden you gain there that is
very useful there sports people who know
all that kind of data I don't know I
don't know what I would know trying to
come up with something ultra useful not
something just ultra cool and I think I
would want the ability to read a book
and be able to access all the fall the
facts on them you're a lot better at
retaining information and I am so I feel
like if only one of us can get this has
got to be me like I'm really hurting for
this like I need this one so that's a
good one or you take it now but you know
another useful memory skill you know how
when something happens to you and then
into settings to everybody and then you
want it to sit down and tell the story
and you can't quite get everything right
being able to remember exactly how
something happened to you like almost
for the sake of like telling a funny
story at a party only a witness stand
yeah that was also be that would be just
being able to remember detailed events
with great accuracy I'd be I get hit in
the head with a golf ball for that it's
it's difficult when you can't apply to
other people's situations like I'd much
rather be you know if it only applies
the things you've experienced you can't
help with so many people but if you know
a lot of things you could help out other
people let me tell you about this this
guy that I'm really interested in
because I would much rather have what
this guy has okay
Alonzo Clements from Boulder Colorado
was always good with his hands at the
age of two he could sculpt and mold
play-doh for hours at a time but when he
was three years old he fell down and
sustained a serious head injury okay
changed his life forever he was four
years he was unable to speak tie his
shoes even dress himself doctor said he
had an IQ of 40 well to this day Alonzo
I mean he's made tremendous strides in
terms of his quality of life but he
still can't read because that part of
his brain it just won't allow him to the
the damage that he suffered however if
you put a piece of clay in his hands you
will be amazed what this guy can do with
it he there is a genius part of his
brain that's been unlocked to sculpt
things he can look at any animal a horse
a dolphin a bullet giraffe name it just
a few moments and then using only his
hands in clay he can create an insanely
detailed three-dimensional replica out
of clay or wax like perfect um this is
not like a work of art like oh that
looks cool an approximation of a horse
this is a perfect proportional rendering
anatomically correct externally he
doesn't get the organs inside right just
like from the look it's like perfectly
super realistic sculpture of anything
the images in his mind are the only
thing he uses for for reference like
he'll look at a horse once if you like I
saw footage of him like outside of a
horse stable and he's like sculpting a
horse but he's not looking at the horse
he looked at the horse for a sec got it
I got any horse Yun it's like a 3d
printer this guy is a 3d printer he is a
human 3d printer that's exactly what I
need one made this guy the images inter-
only clay though in his mind are so
accurate he even Incan sculpt in the
dark without even looking at what his
hands are doing from here it's just all
by feel that's what they say man for
years his work was only based on
photographs so his sculptures didn't
have as much dimension because he didn't
he only saw the the pictures but then he
started going to zoos horan horse
stables like people would take in the
manimals and then he was like spitting
out like a 3d image you're exactly right
this guy would be like the ultimate zoo
companion you know the corner yeah every
guy's yeah I did I'm a big on the zoo
it's always a disappointment there all
the animals are always hiding you need a
sculpture
so be like listen man I know that the
Lions are gonna be back there sleeping
behind the rock but so when we get there
can you just like sculpt one he is it's
not even that he is able to do it he's
compelled to do it like he can't help do
help but do it that's it's like so
strong of an urge and some of that like
neurological explanations I've read have
said things they've described it as this
we all have this ability but that for
for most people it's overwritten by
complex speech abilities that have been
erased for Alonzo and it kind of exposed
something so it you know I don't know
why they say this but they describe it
as something that's been exposed or
opened up not something that's been
created by trauma again you're saying
that we could do this if we could only
access that part of the brain yeah
savants like Alonzo can store
information in their memories just like
regular people do but unlike most of us
they can retrieve incredible amounts of
information from a very strong small
range like spatial data he can retrieve
it
just like the piano guy can retrieve
details or the weather guy can retrieve
that those specific details it's did you
sell this stuff they sell a website
yeah he has a website Alonzo Clemens CL
e mo NS dot-com like he's selling like a
hippo mama and a hippo baby for $1,200
oh wow this is all like bronze stuff
it's not cheap but it's super inspiring
I got you know the videos online if you
just search his name they're very
inspirational so yeah I mean he's he
demonstrates his sculpting at schools to
help inspire children and he's also had
a hobby as a power lifter and was in the
Special Olympics for doing powerlifting
dudes amazing thing here's the thing in
general I mean the brain
so fascinating this kind of has given us
a window into oh yeah if you want to
call it the untapped potential okay you
know I the mystery that is our brain is
so fascinating so amazing so enthralling
what we we look at technology and we're
like oh I gotta have that next thing
that's amazing that now we've created
that thing but this has given me an
appreciation for this device that is
nestled under our everybody's skull like
we all have this device that's so
mysterious and so amazing and untapped
and unfathomable to a lot of degree
inexplicable that we're cute we're just
carrying it around on the top of this so
what I'm gonna do
heap of daunting human Matt walk walk
alert walker thing well inside the
Walker thing in order to get to the but
it's right up here we all have it
and all we gotta do is push real hard
while we're using the bathroom get
struck by lightning don't wear a helmet
while playing baseball don't wear your
seatbelt while driving car what other
things what other things yes sir or just
just fall over and aggressively all just
fall if it were only that easy right
well I mean I really think about I mean
growing up the huge televisions we had
in the 80s and if it didn't work what
would you do you go up to the side of it
and you'd hit it yeah and it worked like
even in Mad Men in the last season I
don't know if you remember that but
there's that moment where I can't
remember which character it was goes up
and hits the side of the television and
that's one of the things I love about
men man is that it triggers these
memories you can't do that to a
television anymore cuz because this it's
too thin you don't want to hit the
screen you need a box they need to bring
the box back so you can just really hit
it that's because it wasn't I mean I'm
not gonna even say why cuz I don't know
but had something to do with the tube
but you know it's I
I'm not gonna say well I'm gonna try
really hard to unlock this potential but
it's just knowing that I have this thing
up there that's it's like carrying
around like the depths of the ocean or
the depths of space long between my ears
plumb the depths between your ears
that's that's the motto but I'm using
your plumbing analogy of us I'm bringing
out our motto
I'm bringing it full circle plumb the
depths between your ears I don't know if
that means you know put more stuff in
there
- Utley don't think it means don't wear
a helmet but I don't know just sit
around and wait for the nanotechnology
pill that'll make all this easy I hope
you've been fascinated I hope you've
been inspired to appreciate and begin to
plumb the depths between your ears today
on this ear basically
please do that let us know what you
think tweet at us use your brain at
rhettandlink has tagged ear biscuits to
access the emotional and computational
and memory parts of your brain and
access that part of the brain turn it
into language it could be Mandarin it
could be English you can make a
sculpture of what you think that we look
like right now while we're doing this
take an Instagram whatever do it plumb
the depths between your ears must be
catch you next week
[Music]
[Music]